opening the meeting for the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court of the State of New
Hampshire and it is good to welcome back
Christina Dyer thank you your substitute
Wednesday Adams filled in admirably for
you in fact bore a
significant
similarity but good to have you back
anyway I'm going to ask for reports from
the working groups we had four working
groups and off you went to discuss
various
things um before uh we start the speaker
would like to have an interim report
from this group so when each work group
makes your report we will
probably ask a few things to be included
in it if it you know if it's it's good
and ask you to get it back to us pretty
quickly so then uh next week at our
meeting um we can vote on this being
part of our
report uh I would like to start with the
committee on forms and the chair
recognizes the wife of the street and
sidewalk commissioner from the city of
nesa newly elected thank you Mr chairman
yeah he's Board of Public Works but
we're very excited for him very excited
for NASA actually so U thank you though
so I'm sorry I'm not so you just want me
to give you the update on what we're
where we're at with our fors committee
and stuff correct our report okay just
give us an update you threw me with that
introduction it was very exciting so
with uh the subcommittee on forms we
actually had a meeting well first
actually judge Ashley came and spoke
before the entire committee and really
gave us a very informative update on
where they are with forms I think that
there's been a consensus that they have
been paying attention but even before
that they were already aware that there
were some hiccups in the forms they went
from having you know each Court area
having different forms to all getting
the same forms so now that they all have
the same they're they're looking at how
can they simplify that in our
subcommittee meeting um we met with uh a
court uh a clerk and um what was great
about that was actually actually it was
it was unintentional unintentional but
representative ball was there and you
were there uh chairman Pearson and
representative ball actually
demonstrated how it's actually hard to
find the forms on the website so they
were able to see that firsthand but they
do have steps going forward starting
with the fact that right now they're
getting um they're getting quotes on
people that can come in and kind of work
through the forms and stuff there also
what's the technical term request for
for it's an r r anybody remember what
that is
anybody RFP yes request for proposal
yeah request for proposal so they need
to do that they're hoping to get figure
out which company in the next six months
and then they'll start working they are
going to have some feedback they have
been paying attention they have been
watching the feedback that we have um
one of the things that we talked about
is making it more accessible um we did
demonstrate to them a legal aid a New
Hampshire legal aid they have a page
that's very easily traversed and so
they're also looking at that they were
going to talk to um them about who they
use to see if there's something that
they can do that would also follow that
because it is so easy to look at so what
we decided after at that subcommittee
meeting was really just to keep
Communication open we'll keep those
lines open but I don't think there's
anything necessary really from us other
than if they ask for feedback and I'm
interested to check in with them I have
it on my calendar to check in in a few
months to see how those rfps went and to
see where they are in that process but
they are hoping they have funds to do it
so they're hoping within the next year
or so to start having some
implementations you invited three people
to the subcommittee meeting did you I
did and I um well what kind of people
well from the nice people I know that
they were from the courts and I I knew
that you were going to ask me first and
I should have had it ready but instead
we were talking so I apologize so we had
um okay so we had the Heather Culp who
is the Circuit Court senior
administrator and then we also had
Elaine um low who is the Conway clerk
oan Conway Clerk and um judge Ashley was
here actually the time before so we did
not have her come back so uh both of
those came back and um then there were
three of us so it was a really small
meeting it was warmer that day than the
time before uh but yeah that was that
was really our work unfortunately Ely
and this is how it should be the
judicial branch had already taken the
the steps to go ahead and start start
fixing this issue they knew it was an
issue they could see uh as they've been
watching our committee meetings um the
level of the issue so they were already
taking those necessary steps but I do
think from Judge Ashley it was already
kind of in their plan it just spurred
them to do it a little bit quicker so I
think we're in a really good place with
that at the end of the meeting you'll
recall I asked the clerks would mind
terribly if we kind of insinuated oursel
into the process and you remember their
response they not only did they not mind
it they said that welcome it yes they're
very open to communication and feedback
and that's that's also why right now I
think they said it would they thought it
would take about um actually they're
thinking that um the overall work might
be done in six months so at that six to
N9 months so in two months is when I
have marked on my calendar to check in
with them and see where we are and see
if they need any feedback but they also
have uh contacts for all of us and we
have their contacts so that way if
something comes up for us we can tell
them but also if they have any questions
so they do know that that we've gotten a
lot of comments and stuff on the forms
and just um so they know that they can
contact us on that too so open
communication when we started this
special committee or even before we
first met I met with the uh Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court and also
administrative judge David King and
suggested that
um I want to gang up with them to fix
problems rather than ganging up against
them we've seen too much of ganging up
against people and they said that's what
they would like as well somebody said
did I trust them I said yes until they
give me reason not to and they haven't
and they are listening to what we do
whether live or you know by recording
and anticipating and it was to me a
tremendous thing to go in and here
they're already doing it even before we
told them to yeah would you write up
everything you just
recited and send it to us in the next
couple days please so we can vote on
this absolutely I have it I have it
written up so I will send it to everyone
were you reading that only looking like
you were no I was trying to find it
still I'm not that prepared I need like
coffee through the IV today well I
thought you did a good job thank you so
send us all that and we can read it over
the weekend and vote on it next week
sounds good thank you thank you um so
that's the um special subcommittee group
on
forms I'd like to call on Vice chair
Smith if you would for judicial training
education supervision and accountability
and RSA
4049 f.6 should be
reviewed good morning morning Mr chair
um and I um will not be as
um as thorough or complete as my
nashille colleague because I've been
struggling with with some of this and uh
and I know those on the subcommittee
have been
struggling and it begins Mr chair
because family court cases are among the
most complex
that a circuit court judge
faces even if a judge is familiar with
the law and almost no judges appointed
to the Circuit Court
are the application of the
law might very well have no bearing on
solving the painful complex
idiosyncratic questions that brought the
party to the court Court in the first
place we um have
listened
carefully as I think everyone has to the
testimony the very painful testimony
that has been presented to this
committee um but in addition we have
tried to identify sources that
um uh per perhaps bring some more
neutral
perspective to the to the uh the issues
because we do have to acknowledge that
overwhelmingly uh probably no one wants
to be in the Family Court they just
assume not have those problems that have
to be resolved but in most
cases um they're resolved
with people not not necessarily all
feeling happy um but
uh willing
to attempt to abide by the the judges
decisions um and those people who have
come before us um as important as their
experience is and I don't think any of
us would want to minimize that do not
necessarily represent the
mainstream of those people who go
through the
court but it is important to take
seriously what they
say we uh looked at materials that came
from a lot of sources but the one that
um I know I found particularly helpful
is the Family Justice
initiative principles for Family Justice
Reform that were published in 2019 not
that long ago by the national uh Center
for state
courts and their General thinking is
something that I want to share with
everybody and I hope we will share in
our
report divorce separation and parental
responsibility cases often present
complicated emotional and non Le legal
issues requiring a family court judge to
have familiarity with theories and
research in disciplines such as Social
Work psychology and dispute
resolution the principles in this report
and in others include understanding
Child Development family Dynamics child
abuse substance abuse relevant
intervention strategies and standards
have to be applied
in order to end up with outcomes that
might be helpful at all and then you
have issues like bankruptcy law
immigration which I hadn't focused on
but is incredibly important and criminal
law and so
um to begin with as
chair I question the basic premise that
the judicial arena is the appropriate
place to resolve these
differences um who is looking at each
case to identify Child Development
issues implicit bias and other
nonjudicial but extremely relevant
factors but charged with addressing the
obvious problems within the existing
structure there are certain threshold
issues the need to sure that those
appointed to sit on Family Law Court
matters on the Circuit Court have
relevant education and
experience and in situations where they
have
experience there has to be an
evaluation of how they
performed in those
circumstances um once appointed
we believe strongly that the newly
seated judge must undergo training
focusing on the intricacies of the
family
court in order for the judge to carry
out his or her judicial duties the
Circuit Court Staffing must mirror that
of the Supreme and Superior Courts and
that there must be a sufficient number
of Clerks to support the justices now
you might wonder why charged with
looking at EX at
education um and accountability we would
presume to mention the presence or
absence of
Clerks um we think it's
Central to how the judges are able to
carry out their
business um they have
to do everything that they have to do
sitting at the bench they have to write
the reports they have to process the
report they have to make sure that the
extraneous information and materials are
involved all of this makes it impossible
to devote the appropriate amount of time
to actually carrying out the direct
judicial duties we know that there are
time lags that we shouldn't have in the
system and believe that having
additional staff support could make that
important we know that in many cases the
decision is
written in um almost in if not
necessarily in shorthand but in in an
abbreviated manner where um they the
judge says yeah I decided X but does not
have the time time to say and the reason
I decided X is because this was the
testimony this is what I found uh from
supporting or opposing documents um this
is why I ended up where I did it's all
well and good to make a decision but
unless people know why that decision is
made it might be very hard for them to
accept it and so all of that could be
helped if there were in fact enough
staff support um
uh we then um we did look at uh Supreme
Court
um uh rule five we looked at the
memorandum from judges Dave King and
Susan Ashley that was dated October
2nd and
um we
on the one hand we're very pleased that
they recognized that we needed to
um have an organized educational effort
but
truthfully and this is my per this is
not anything that I I don't know if
anybody else agrees but personally I was
surprised that understanding the absence
of Staff the cas loads the pressure all
the other things that need to be done
that the proposal was to create um uh
the I don't have the page in front of me
unfortunately because couldn't carry it
all today given the weather um but to
create something called roughly the you
know new New Hampshire judicial training
College um with all due
respect we're a long way from needing a
training College what we need is someone
on the staff who has the responsibility
for making sure that every judge has
access to the
training that is essential for them to
carry out their jobs and that they have
the time to take advantage of that
training not 6 months or 12 months after
they have started in the family family
courts but at the beginning and all of
that I understand costs money and the
the money component is the
responsibility of the
legislature but it is important for the
judicial branch to
understand to be committed to explaining
to to the legislature is is the better
way of putting it I think that they
understand the need for training the
need for supervision the need for
accountability and that they H in fact
have a plan to do that the last thing
the legislature should be doing is doing
the judicial Branch's business and um
there's much more to be said much more
to be looked at I think I've probably
talked long enough to give you a
feeling of um of of where we're going
and um I hope hope you will accept the
fact that our report that we will submit
to you next week will be a preliminary
report and um hoping that we will have
opportunity to um do a lot more in terms
of identifying best practices across the
country and relating those to the
realities of how the New Hampshire court
system operates and the hope that
we can get all of us closer to the best
possible system thank you Mr chair and
with that I would ask anyone else who
served on the judicial training
education supervision accountability
subcommittee if you have something to
add to what the subgroup chair has just
eloquently given us this is a time to
say it anyone else from that
subcommittee
hearing nothing would you type that all
up and send it out over the weekend to
us please I I will do my best and as I
have emailed before what I would like is
um just also list who is in
attendance at the
meetings Okay I I as I say I will do the
best that I can I'm sure you will and
we'll look at all of this now over the
weekend and come back uh as many of us
as can next Tuesday to make some uh
decisions about a preliminary interim
report next subcommittee was the
g/ pent parenting coordinator role and
um who do I call upon for that did you
Che that didn't you I did but I wasn't
there but I'll you to speak on it I do
watch it but you tun T in yes of course
you did yes so you were the named chair
so if you could give us the lead off and
then we could call on the others who
were there as well sure so the GP
parting coordinator subcommittee met I
unfortunately wasn't able to make it so
representative long was kind enough to
fill in as chair for me that day thank
you very much rep long he wrote that to
victory in the Manchester election by
the way wonderful
and um uh attorney uh Erin crean from
the court attended as well and was there
to answer many questions as well as took
home quite a few questions that the
group had she was able to respond to um
many of the questions I think there was
one outstanding question that I had in
my notes um and I think at this point
the group needs to come together based
on the information that we've received
and see what
further may need to be done so my
recommendation would be that we have
another meeting to see if we have enough
data based on the information that we
got back from attorney KGAN to be able
to make any recommendations or if we
feel like we need to do any more
research but I do think that we do need
to have another meeting as a
subcommittee uh to go over the
information we've received and see a
path
forward and in terms of the the the
parenting coordinator piece I did prior
to the filing deadline put in kind of a
placeholder bill so that we'd have
something in there it was as thorough as
I could be for the parenting coordinator
piece but the gal piece is something
that's really already in there and
so that's much more involved so there's
no placeholder for that and that would
be the place where I think we really
need to discuss and see what may need to
be done there if anything and what our
recommendations will be because the
other piece of it is a financial piece
in that much of what we heard was that
Indigent parties who can't afford a g
are often turned away
and it's not a budget year so I'm not
sure
that that's necessarily going to be
possible now but maybe that's more of a
recommendation that we make for the next
budget so I think we really need to come
back together and discuss all of that I
have reserved because of calendar
deadline issues next Tuesday November
14th at 9:30 for the special committee
as a work session and just keep that in
the back of your mind it might be one or
two of the subcommittees could be
meeting and then all of us at say 11
o'clock or something if you know this is
just an ill formed thought trying to
coales uh just hold that idea or maybe
you would want to schedule a meeting of
this subcommittee for a little bit later
on that would come past our deadline for
making our interim report possibly or we
could schedule another meeting of the
whole subcommittee later on I mean this
is just all options we have but we would
like to get the interim report in uh
this year Vice chair please um Mr chair
could you flesh out your idea
frequently interim reports are um tend
to be brief and tend to
identify not so much what has happened
but where the you know the the body
wants to go my understanding is that we
have another full year we do before we
have a detailed final report and all of
that one would hope would be done and
distributed so that information that
might AFF affect the next budget process
would already
be people would be aware of it but so I
I just want to know how much you really
want for this um interim report I think
we want something more than a sketchy
outline and something less than a
complete final report okay thank you
somewhere on the Continuum Mr chair
squaring the circle okay yes and in
terms of discussion not only
is the Judiciary paying attention and
walking with us and sometimes actually
leading us on um I get to meet with the
chairman of
Finance at least once a week we both
represent Kingston and East Kingston and
um he is uh really starting to warm up
to the suggestion of not only in the
next budget do we need more judges we
need clerks in the Circuit Court we need
a trainer we need supervisors uh I'm
feeding it to him in ways that uh he
understands how financially this is a
very responsible thing to do that is
wonderful news Mr chairman I do want to
point out to you that it is
theoretically
possible that the distinguished
representative with whom I have served
on finance for many years might in fact
not be the chair of the finance
committee it could be we also know that
no matter what happens the incumbent
Governor will not be the governor and uh
by this this coming spring the budget
process itself actually begins to start
with each of the Departments MH having
to begin to get information in so that
it is also a very good news that you
give us that the judicial branch is
paying attention and one would hope
would make sure that some of of these
directions are reflected in the um in
the plan that they're probably almost
ready to begin on for the next budget
well I'm keeping my eye on developments
and right now I intend to dance with the
gal I brought to the dance and should
something happen along the way I am
flexible I'm delighted to hear that and
um I'm can't very well dance right now
but I would do it if I could and perhaps
you and I could
meet thank you the uh fourth of the four
working group groups was on the subject
of Rules of Evidence and you know as
you're making your um wish list for next
month I hardly recommend and I believe
representative Greg would agree with me
that you put on your wish list the Rules
of Evidence almost 300 Pages it doesn't
come stained doged and watermarked
that's because I've read it through four
times slowly L read the footnotes looked
up the cross references it's a great
book I'm just waiting for the movie to
come out so here's my report as chairman
of the Rules of Evidence
subcommittee additional members were
Representatives ball Greg Long and
McMahon these five are all from the
children and family law committee
because that
committee uh would later have to decide
on House Bill 47 75 establishing a right
to submit evidence in testimony and
family court proceedings and House Bill
499 requiring The Rules of Evidence to
apply in family court cases and relative
to the admission of certain evidence and
family court proceedings to use their uh
titles so the reason I picked the five
of us from children and family law to be
this subcommittee is we would be dealing
with it anyway and here we are now I was
given
this uh copy of Rules of Evidence it is
subtitled with reporter's notes as
updated by the New Hampshire Bar
Association Rules of Evidence committee
published in
2023 testimony before
our special
committee this special committee as well
as before children and family law often
centered
around as the people giving testimony
said how a judge refused to to accept
proferred pieces of evidence for from
one of the litigant or refused an
objection to the acceptance of evidence
from the other litigant in other words
the whole question of Rules of Evidence
was a source of much
testimony and the two bills submitted to
us would put strong um restrictions
prohibitions mandates on the judge Judes
they demanded one of them demand many of
them demanded judges except all evidence
proferred in in and in any form
unlimited as one Bill said by the
presiding judge magistrate or marital
master or by the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence or the rules of the Circuit
Family Circuit Court Family Division in
other words if somebody wants a piece of
evidence in that piece of evidence must
come in assertions were made that this
or that judge was biased in One
Direction or another based on a
perceived imbalance in rulings about
evidence always favored the woman or
always favored the man or would take
anything or would take nothing we
remember those
hearings several things emerged as I
read through the book Rules of Evidence
allows a judge to refuse a piece of
evidence to be
admitted if it does not enhance the case
that is it does not add or detract from
the likely verdict now if the judge did
not have the power to do that the trial
could go on indefinitely people could
keep bringing in more quote evidence and
the judge would have his or her hands
bound must accept it and yet we keep
hearing from testimony the cases drag on
too long well folks you can't have it
both ways piece page 31 each single
piece of evidence must have a plus value
well according to whom one of the bills
said according to the person who gives
it well of course but who says that
person is
unbiased of course well should the judge
not hold the discretionary power
ultimately to decide whether a piece of
evidence enhances the case or is simply
dragging it on secondly Rules of
Evidence allows the judge to refuse a
piece of evidence to be admitted if its
probative value was substantially
outweighed by the danger of unfair
Prejudice for those of you um who are
not familiar with the legal term that
means the value that's probative the
value of a piece of evidence to prove
something is much smaller than the
potential inappropriate harm either to
the case or to another person and this
is a case where we've heard testimony
too the other side dragged in a piece of
evidence which really didn't help the
case but served to ridicule the opponent
and I think we've heard objections to
that so if the judge cannot rule the
probative value being less than likely
harm then we're going to see a lot more
of weaponization of evidence page
39 Rules of Evidence allows for the
judge to refuse evidence of other crimes
when prior bad acts are in some
significant way connected to material
events constituting the crime charged
and not so remote in time as to
eliminate the Nexus what that basically
means means is you cannot bring in
evidence of a past crime if it's only
tangentially related to the uh case at
hand for example in a sexual matter uh
one could not drag in all kinds of
things that somebody did in college if
it has no or minimal relevance and only
serves to embarrass uh that's page 65
now I could go on for a long time I was
actually having fun doing this but I
think you get the point in each of the
three examples in my opinion it must be
up to the judge to decide whether
something is relevant inappropriately
harmful whether it's connected and so on
these are judgment calls and in one case
it the decision could go one way in
another case it could go that way
because they're not always exactly
identical so no fixed law or rule can
accurately fit every case this is why on
several occasions Rules of Evidence the
book States clearly The Rules of
Evidence are not mandatory in Circuit
Court they're they give guidance but the
judge has to use discretion and Research
indicates this is how civil court Works
in Most states and in a few where a
wooden literal following
of the Rules of Evidence is mandated It
is believed that a substantial Advantage
is given to the litigant who is a lawyer
or who has studied the law extensively
over against the litigant prosay who is
neither a lawyer nor well study but
simply representing him or
herself uh that seems to be the answer
um that I'm hearing as I spot checked so
the conclusion that um our
subgroup which really was a subcommittee
of children and family law came up
with is we ultimately must not tie the
hands of the judges
however there does seem to be a few
judges where bias intentional or
otherwise might possibly be
true so if we can't tie their
hands and yet there seems to be
a pattern that we should not want how do
we Square this
circle during the executive session in
children and family law I introduced an
amendment
2023-2024
which would replace one of the bills in
its entirety and the amendment reads
this way if the court admits evidence or
testimony over the objection of one of
the parties or the court chooses is not
to admit evidence or testimony offered
by one of the parties the court shall
note in the record the reason for its
decision if the belief is that the
judges always rule in a wise fair and
impartial manner it should admit no
embarrassment for the judge to say this
is why I Ruled because the judge
believes him or herself to be wise fair
and impartial and that's why the judge
made the ruling to admit or exclude a
piece of evidence so just tell us why
I'm sure you knew why that's why you did
it so no penalty there to probably just
about everybody but my suggestion to the
Judiciary is that they significantly
increase the review of cases
particularly of those judges where a
significant number of
concerns have been raised about that
judge's evidentiary
rulings such review May correctly
conclude that this judge was after all
wise fair and impartial in most if not
all of his or her rulings or the
conclusion might go in another Direction
warranting some continuing
education warranting monitoring of a
particular judge something that by the
way happens now but we would suggest
should happen more and if this problem
persists perhaps some disciplinary
action could be taken an escalating
thing where someone somehow is not
responding to the continuing education
to bring that judge back into some kind
of balance now I believe this amendment
this
suggestion for monitoring would address
the question of alleged impropriety
while not not hamstringing the judges
where they need to have discretion trust
but verify for the record House Bill 475
is amended by the amendment I just read
passed the children and family law
committee 16 to Zer and the somewhat
parallel bill now that we've dealt with
the issue uh was itl 16 to zero my
recommendation uh to all of us is that
we give the above a try for a year if it
works we squared the circle and if it
doesn't we can always come back and try
again so that's my report as chairing
the subcommittee on Rules of Evidence
and uh anyone from that subcommittee uh
wishes to
speak uh not accepting
anything no whatever but I'm not
accepting anything so anybody from the
uh subcommittee wish to comment uh
representative uh McMahon long Greg or
ball
no I'm
sorry yeah you articulated it well
that's exactly what I what I
recalled I think we I I think all of us
working together came to a pretty good
similar place so that is that is pretty
much my report and I will email it to
everybody representative uh Madam Vice
chair thank you very much that was a
very thorough and impressive report and
I thank you very much for it one of uh
thought that struck me is how closely so
much of what you discussed um
intersected with the concept of of
training
supervision etc etc and also the need
for
clerks um in order to be able to do what
you
specifically direct the judges to do
which is to record in more detail than
they would have the time or ability to
do under these
circumstances why they have made certain
decisions
so that coming in in your Silo so to
speak and the training supervision
accountability Silo we end up at the
same place and that I think indicates
that we might be on the right track
Madame Vice chair if if I may I would
like to take what you just said and add
it to my report with with a footnote of
course uh just to to talk about how two
of the subcommittees working on somewhat
different things have come to very
similar conclusions at the meeting place
so I think I'd like to do that good yes
representative McBeth oh so actually I
had a question you hadn't called for
that yet I think you were asking other
members of the committee too well okay
other members on the committee
representative MC
Beth so um the bill I at the I was
following you and then at the end you
got kind of fast talking I do
that um I could be a lawyer so
clarification so you're there's a bill
that the family law committee or is
going to put forward two bills and
you're going to ask or require uh Family
Court judges to within their orders
write Regarding why they did or did not
accept evidence I mean generally that's
something that's done from the bench I
think in a transcript or an audio
recording that you can get for $25 would
provide that information but I are you
asking cuz you know we've seen the
evidence that we've gotten 25 Pages 100
pages so I'm just wanted to clarify are
you asking for a written explanation
about evidentiary rulings within a
family court proceeding House Bill 475
is amended and passed by CFL committee
16 to0 onto consent would do exactly
that that if a judge says no I'm not
allowing that piece of evidence in there
is a note as to why and it may be a very
brief phrase or if yes over the
objection of the other litigant I am
accepting that piece of evidence here's
why um so I would ask I mean that that
for me and I'm you know my experience is
only limited to mine but in a you know
in a family court hearing even a 30
minute hearing you I mean you could have
20 rulings on individual package of 100
pieces and the recording of that I mean
um I I think it goes back to only
representative Smith said yeah um well
no if you're going to submit evidence um
doesn't have to be an objection you're
still going to have to whoever's trying
no no it's only if there's an
objection your bills okay yeah yeah only
if there's an
objection and therefore the judge has to
make a ruling if there's no objection
there it is but if there is an objection
there has to be a ruling we just simply
believe the judge knows what he or she
is doing and then not just pulling
rabbits out of hats and since the judge
knows what he or she is doing give me a
phrase as to why um it does not enhan
does not Advance the case period or its
probative value is outweighed by harm to
others or the case simply write it
down that that I think that definitely I
mean my experience is only my own but
judge I my experience is that New
Hampshire judges and family court do
they don't just say no they'll say if
there's an objection lack of foundation
okay or whatever but um then it's
written down it will be written down the
transcript will be well well it's not
written in the order it's it's in the
transcript I guess that's what I'm
trying to okay okay I'm just that's a
lot of yeah the allegations were made
that judges arbitrarily do this and
numbers of people say and we were never
told why I'm not going to argue whether
that is Truth or
Fiction let's say for the purpose of
argument it's truth the judge made a
ruling and never said why now the judge
will say why and if the judges almost
always say why there will be very few
cases where this amendment actually
forces the judge to do something
else and just to clarify then uh the
litigant would go back and look at the
transcript and then if the judge didn't
say why that would be brought
forward we will I suspect leave that to
the Judiciary how they wish to do it my
hope would be an administrative
clerk hearing or getting wi the judge
Snodgrass I hope there's no judge
Snodgrass in New Hampshire if there is I
apologize or any of us have relatives
named Snodgrass judge XYZ how's that um
the rumor on the street is XYZ always
favors this side well okay let's go spot
check or somebody on appeal and remember
to appeal it must be an error in law or
procedure it isn't just I lost I hate
that I'm appealing you know that uh I
learned that uh those would be the cases
I what I want to do is to be able to say
to those who have come in here and said
a certain thing that we hear it and to
the degree we you know we're able to do
this we want to answer it I personally
would be very surprised there would be a
lot of cases where the judge is
Prejudice but let's find that out I'd
like to be proven no there isn't but if
there is we need to know that that's all
this is doing is I don't want to use the
phrase Silence the Critics I want to
take I want to listen to what the
critics are saying and to the degree
they're correct I want there to be some
changes and to the degree they're wrong
stop making these
criticisms representative long thank you
Mr chairman uh and and with that also uh
the the CFL committee did consider the
added burden on the judges that how it
would be more complicated or give them
more work and we came to the conclusion
that it you know it was just a note as
to why or why not and it was only for
evidence that he didn't accept or one
litigant was able to put in evidence and
the other litigant was not able to
so give me a footnote as to why the
other litigant wasn't a you know wasn't
able to so it's not on every um every
order that you know every order with
respect to evidence that the judge makes
it's not that um the high number of pro
a the judge may have said I'm not
considering that issue so I'm not
accepting your evidence as a pro say I
forget that as soon as I walk out the
door and I'm thinking hey how come he
didn't take my evidence I I didn't hear
it uh this way here it's written
everybody knows and it it just makes it
clearer and makes it easier for the
prosay uh to know that they're um you
know they they're being considered and
they have clear reason why uh evidence
was taken or not taken in in their cases
I I mean it's addressing the prosay more
or less and and that's uh that's what
the legislators uh hear most is from
prosay people that um you know feel that
they're being biased against and you
know we we're we're looking to uh we're
looking to give him a clearer
understanding in a way it also levels
the field because if somebody says
objection the next thing the judge will
say is on what grounds
and I don't like it isn't grounds for
you know making an objection so one of
the litigant say objection your honor
the objector should give a reason and
when the judge makes a ruling the judge
should have a
reason representative McBeth so I
understand and I appreciate it I've
approached this a little bit differently
when um allegations of wrongdoing or or
or inadequate explanations have been
provided as you know uh testimony and
I've talked with the uh citizens that
have come I've asked them to show me I
thought that you know what what the
proof of what they are alleging and at
that's the point where they can't
provide it so as far as um I'm you know
there you children and family law has
done a lot The annotation of that type
of a decision I can't imagine how um
much how I mean I don't I have never
I've I don't see that on um you know US
Supreme court cases so I just I'm I I I
you know that's another book I haven't
read we're just dealing with but no I I
mean and I but um you
know I think you'll be able to work it
out and I think you know it is important
to respond to the citizens and what
their concerns are and to try to figure
out to do that in a way that balances um
you know good judicial process and time
that we have see if a family court case
at least one of the parties had a lawyer
the lawyer would speak with the client
ahead of time about evidence and whether
it should be offered is there's
foundation for offering that evidence
and if there isn't any I'm sure the
lawyer would say well he's going to rule
against you so don't bother but in a
proos say well that's not my experience
well okay and that that's why I haven't
gone to law school yet um I understand
this will come up in the first year with
contracts but never mind
um 80%
has one or both parties prosay in Family
Court we've been repeatedly told so they
may not know
this that you better have a reason for
asking a piece of evidence to be
admitted and why it might be ruled
against you but many people don't so
this this will level the field I think
anything else anyone else on Rules of
Evidence I will add your wonderful
comments about how it connects and get
this out to you over the weekend
now one question we've had four
subcommittees and the question before us
will be does the subcommittee can need
to meet more or are we done
forms okay done judicial
training
I I'm I'm not confident about an answer
right now on that I do know the reality
is that all of us are
scrambling to go down two roads right
now one finish all the bills that we
have from last session and prepare for
the bills that are about to fall on us
for the next session so that I am
hesitant about adding anything that is
not
required there where there's not a time
limit requirement right now but I
would hope that perhaps after the first
of the
year um we could get together again and
say okay now we've had a preliminary
report where do we want to go from here
I just don't
think I don't think it's fair to try to
do something right now I guess it's my
my response so the suggestion is let's
put this on the back burner and revisit
getting the band back together again
next year that would be my suggestion
but it's just my that's good others in
that work group what do you
think I hear
nodding okay good
Rules of Evidence I really think we're
done um g/p parenting coordinator
representative katab is speaking of a
placeholder bill on parenting
coordinator and I think I heard you say
that more Works to work needs to be done
on gal so you'd like your subgroup to
continue yes please okay I don't think
that it needs to be something that's
urgently done because I I guess I don't
want to speak for the committee but I
asking if you feel this way that this is
something more that we can put into the
final report rather than necessarily
proposing a bill right now causing us to
urgently meet do you feel that we could
put it in the report okay so let's have
it in the preliminary report and maybe
the subcommittee can be back bured for
next year at some point and yeah I can
put together a preliminary report based
on the questions that were asked of
attorney krian and the data that we've
gotten so far as well as okay you know I
I think uh the parenting coordinator
piece of the parenting SLG had been very
briefly brought up I had put in again
that placeholder bill for it and I think
because of that it was more focusing on
the gal piece but I think we were kind
of okay with what we had what had been
put forward for parenting coordinator am
I okay so the parenting coordinator
piece is kind of in and it's the gal
piece that'll be a report you know going
more details into the final report very
good uh the next
question that I had sent you several
times
is we received a lot of testimony and
the
clerks put them into categories from
which four subcommittees were formed I
have down here here on a print out um a
couple of other perhaps categories to
start a new subcommittee and I have down
here child
support and domestic violence and sense
representative your fingerprints are on
both of these would you speak to them
please so the child support piece um rep
ball and I worked over the summer to try
and talk to many of the stakeholders
about of this including the family law
attorneys and hearing feedback from many
of them we kind of put something
together and then uh Vice chair Smith
was kind enough to meet with um me and
somebody on the other side of the wall
to go over some of what we had come up
with just to get consensus because what
came out of it was we looked back and
there had been child support bill after
child support Bill year after year after
year that's constantly ited and so it's
there were reasons why in the minutes I
went through and I read all of the
minutes that I that were available um
and tried to see what are the reasons
that it's being ited and make sure that
this bill wasn't going to be in conflict
with the reasons where it previously
been itl because I think much of the
testimony that we heard is is parents
need help on this especially when
there's the Shared Parenting Time and
parties are making approximately equal
amounts of money if parent a makes $10
more than parent B they're then ordered
to pay the full child support amount
which may be $1,000 a month and then the
other parent is in essence then making
more money than this parent and it's
difficult for them to then afford to do
the things that they need to be able to
do with their kids
so that that piece there is a bill in
for that and it is my hope that since
there was so much input on that that the
bill will finally pass this
year is that a 2023 bill that was
retained no that's a 2024 Bill correct
so is it your belief
that that's where all the heavy lifting
should be done is around that particular
bill and we will not need a special
subcommittee of us or
not I don't believe that we will I think
you
know I'd like to hear if anybody else
has any anybody else representative
long thank you Mr chairman um
I that that is as long as I Ser the
children and family law those two are
the issues those are the two that clash
and and and you know it it's it's made
me my decision some times a lot of times
uneasy um but I go for the benefit of
the ad um I I don't believe they need to
be separate
subcommittees um but like representative
uh kab katab said it's it's it's always
been the decision as to why or or not um
good child
support um criterias have been killed
um because of domestic violence uh
getting caught up in the child
support yeah so I I didn't actually
speak to the domestic violence piece I
apologize this was just the child
support piece
um but
the the domestic violence piece
uh I
think that is something that is like ex
kind of put as a criteria for like the
Shared Parenting Time piece why there
may need to be a deviation for that so I
think they're kind of related in some
ways but then not necessarily because
once the parenting time is decided then
the child support is decided afterwards
so um
I the DV piece I did not work on a bet
somebody from the Judiciary Committee
had put in a bill
requiring some or an are requiring
electronic filing uh that's the only
work that I know that's moving forward
as of now regarding domestic
violence so I would be under the
assumption that the child support bill
in 2024 would like its
predecessor come to the children and
family law committee and probably the
best thing to do is when that does land
with us uh we can just set aside a a
good chunk of time and
invite you know but we do not need a
separate subcommittee of this special
committee all the heavy work will be
done in CFL okay yeah that seems to be
the
consensus all right no sub now DV what
about that if you if to your knowled
anybody's knowledge that's the only
DV LSR that was sent in perhaps we do
need a working group on the subject is
that a fair assumption what do you
think I mean the right number to do it
is one not two and not zero
um what do people think representative
Greg is reaching for the button there
she
is thank you I'm not sure that
this I mean part of this and our our you
know looking at the family courts you
know obviously we've had some cases that
have had domestic violence and whatnot
and and we've looked at I just don't
know that that's the charge under here
once again I think that that's something
that will come up in I mean the fact
that we don't have any bills really
filed with DB is is disturbing but I
think the things that we need to look at
are not going to be something that we
would be doing on the special commission
I think once again that would be
something that uh CFL would be carrying
the load on
that
are you about to the chair recognizes
the vice chair for about thank you yes
but a representative Greg said exactly
what I was
thinking
um there is
no no reason for the special
committee
to take
over work of and
responsibility of St standing policy
committees in the
legislature and um we have in the
past had uh experiences not very
pleasant where um we recognized the
cross
um uh the cross over among three
committees really which is the criminal
justice children and family law and
Judiciary on ISS isues relating to
domestic violence but I think in uh I
don't see any reason to put that
responsibility before the the special
committee um I uh I
believe uh I can't speak for for my
colleague from wendam but I believe
that uh the
experience for those of us who were on
Judiciary and not on children and family
uh to be exposed to certain of the
um of the painful
realities uh that people are facing I
we've had an exposure here in this
committee that we haven't necessarily
had in judiciary for example um but I
don't think in the end that it's the
responsibility of the of the special
committee to do that work and so that
the work that that our colleague has
done to actually file some
lsrs I think she has done as an
individual rather than as a
representative of um of this committee
working on knowledge that she gained
from this committee which is how we all
gain knowledge um we certainly don't
want I don't believe we want a new bill
that will come to committees in January
to be assigned to the special
committee representative
ball um Vice chair thank you for
recognizing me um I just had a
clarification
question when you said those other three
committees came together before would
our recommendation um be to bring those
three committees again to look at DV as
in the overall as to whether it should
be in family court or whether it should
be in criminal court or where does it
fall um or just to have an open
discussion because we had so many people
come and testify um so I'm just
wondering if that might be our
recommendation is that there be a
different committee solely to look at
that um that
piece representative B that is a
fascinating question um and I think a
very important
question
um
and I am either happy or unhappy to say
I don't have an answer to that question
um
it
is
possible that we might want to
suggest that
another special Tim
limited committee be
formed perhaps with Representatives
from Criminal Justice children and
family and
Judiciary um to
decide um is there a better
way for the legislative branch to and
therefore
then the results of that would of course
affect the other branches to address the
incredibly serious problem of domestic
vience
um
and the speaker might moan and groan at
the thought of oh dear
but there
might we ought to think about that that
might end up
being a a recommendation that doesn't
fall within any of the standing
committees but recognized
that
all of
those
committees have have an an or in that
boat that's a very interesting idea what
do others think here that in our interim
report of next week we have a line item
that at least suggests perhaps just that
that perhaps a special committee on DV
would be named out of CF Judiciary in
Crim Justice and simply put it
representative long thank you Mr
chairman Ju Just um to I I'm sensing I'm
feeling in
Manchester um the lack of supervised
visitations um there's been arrest in a
library there's exchanges happening in
the library uh police are called in
they're not set up for that in my my
understanding that from the Library
Association that it's worse in town
libraries because it's smaller
Manchester we have security uh we have a
detector you go through uh however in
the smaller towns it's it's more
honorous to get you know a police
officer there when you only get two in a
town um so I so I think that's that's
another you know that that's going to be
coming to a boil uh I think um so um I
think the new committee
uh would suffice that answering those
questions we absolutely need anyone else
who hasn't yet spoken on the issue of
perhaps having this as a line item
recommendation in our interim report
that we'll vote on next week anyone who
hasn't spoken to that
yet thank you the chair recognize his
representative thank you Mr chairman so
I I did speak kind of just that I didn't
think it fell fell under this committee
but um given I mean honestly it's a
global uh uh pandemic of domestic
violence but I do think that you know
even looking at the little kind of tip
of the iceberg that this particular
commission has looked at I think that it
would be very important to have a a
committee like this so I'm very um
versed on what laws we have and what we
don't have in the state and and this is
definitely something that would take an
in
committee not just a little piece of
this one it needs its own focus group on
that here's what I'll do I'll write this
up as a separate Standalone thing
besides what I'm writing for my
subcommittee and on Mon uh Tuesday when
we look at the documents that we're all
working on over the weekend to vote on
them uh we can again address that and
have the weekend to think it through any
yes representative MC Beth thank you m
chairman so I would just comment you
know we had the governor's Commission on
domestic violence that has I mean I
would look at the I mean I will
volunteer to look at what their
recommendations are as far as moving
forward into the legislature but I think
that that really should be our spring
board that work has already been done by
a lot of stakeholders and it was a
considerable amount of time uh with um I
mean every everybody involved so I think
that might be the best place to look as
far as if this committee is going to
make a recommendation I mean to join and
be informed thank you yes um
frequently we
forget in policy committees that um the
stake has already been cut and seasoned
and we don't have to start from square
one we can start from Square Four uh we
forget that too often so thank you for
the reminder representative uh the vice
chair well well thank you I I think I
appreciate representative mcbeth's
comments and of course she's absolutely
right in acknowledging the fact that
there are all kinds of groups out there
addressing um this issue some with more
success um than others some with more um
solid research than others uh some with
different perspectives and what has been
missing I think is a
consistent
legislative
approach and um just as in this
committee we listened to of course to
the courts and to um uh the G group and
we listened to when we had former
Senator and and judge and representative
and chair dead Gordon here with all of
the um all the hats he wears I mean we
benefited a lot from knowing what other
groups have done and some of which we
agree with in the end some of which we
didn't agree with in the end but the the
basic point is is a solid point
I and the other other
important reality is for reasons that we
might surmise but we do not
know domestic violence and related to it
child
abuse um is
um appears to be reaching
pandemic
um level status level and
um I don't think anyone at this table
can feel comfortable unless we try to do
something it might we might not be able
to but at at least we should
try representative
katab so I absolutely agree with putting
this together and it was actually I have
the report right here from the
governor's task force it was actually a
recommendation the recommendation was a
stakeholder group with expertise in the
area of domestic violence should review
existing New Hampshire statutes
regarding domestic violence and
determine whether any of the areas of
review set forth above should be
Advanced through the legislative process
so they did make quite a few
recommendations in here and they did
they did actually recommend a group
getting together and going through that
so I would absolutely support that
somebody suggested this be a these are
my words limited time that it is not
something that goes out a long period
because a lot of the work has been done
and what you just read makes that even
more clear but a group of
legislators reviewing all of this
answering what is said here coming
together to say okay let's put together
an LSR that we can all live with out of
all of this work that's being done would
probably be a limited time but I'll
leave that to other people if I could Mr
chair it's not necessarily an
LSR um we're not going to uh between now
and say June um uh submit an LSR because
we can't right and we shouldn't and and
uh uh but but that is not to say that we
shouldn't
uh do this having nothing to do with the
family court in terms of the process
right now um and have it ready so that
those of us who H will have the um the
privilege of returning to the house
might very well be in a position to file
LSR s and those of us who aren't might
be in a position to help advise those
about who who are here about how to
continue but so it's the purpose isn't
for an LSR the purpose is to say what
should be done by
someone so it would give recommendations
and then an ad hoc group of prime
sponsor co-sponsors would wonderfully
say thank you very much I'll just put my
name on what you said could be or tweak
it because we have to you know could be
okay good thank you
all right I will um I'll have a little
one page that we can vote on
representative long yeah than you just a
quick uh that report date the date on
that
report March 1st
2022 thank you and the title is the
report of the governor's Commission on
DV I have it somewhere so actually so
this one was a task force on domestic
violence cases in the New Hampshire
judicial branch and I have there's a
couple different reports that I have
here um yeah so that was what what came
out of that one so my one pager could
just simply say um and such a group
drawn from these three policy committees
will review various reports from
commissions and judicial branch and you
know make it
Broad and collect new information of
course so there are no new subcommittees
so far there's a one-pager on a
recommendation for a committee to be
formed uh we've got medical training
going to continue on the back burner
we've got gal parenting uh to continue
especially with reference to G that's on
the back burner do we see any new
subcommittees that need to be formed out
of this
group I
don't that looks like a
resounding no but representative Kap so
I don't think we need any more work
groups but I do think that we did
include some other topics which is on
the last page of what you have just
regarding things that should be in the
final report okay and and I think we
should definitely make sure that those
items are addressed in the report I
don't know if they need to be addressed
in the interim but I do think some of
them are are important pieces I know
particularly one of the pieces the
principle of one judge one family and
and the concept of how that can be
honored with the difficulties that the
Judiciary is currently facing and I know
that previously uh Vice chair Smith had
agreed to put put put that together to
take the lead on that one I think
there's a few other topics here I know
obviously the forms ended up getting its
own and I think the visitation piece
might actually be able to be covered a
little bit in the the DV piece because
the visitation piece was more along the
lines of what he was saying where
there's difficulties with exchanges and
whatnot now especially where there's no
there's only the one supervised
visitation
center um
so I think I guess those pieces so those
are two things in the interim report I
can note that over the next year heading
towards the final report we may be
addressing issues such as one judge one
family how about
visitation apart from domestic violence
issues would that be sufficient to look
at so my hope thank you for the question
my hope is
that perhaps some of that can be
addressed through the g/p parenting
coordinator because I do think it's very
difficult a lot of times for the court
to
decipher who may be an appropriate
person for somebody that that perhaps
does need supervis visitation we have a
big substance
abuse epidemic in our in our state and I
think it could be difficult for the
judge to know when you've got you know
one parent that doesn't have a drug
issue with the other parent does and the
parent that's fit and doesn't have the
drug issue is saying no no no to
everybody that the other parent is
coming up with as a possible person it's
difficult for the judge to kind of weigh
and say well are all these people really
having problems or is there a is there
just being unnecessary push back here so
I think a lot of times they don't know
from the bench how could you make that
decision you need somebody else boots on
the ground to actually meet with that
person not as much not as much of a
level as DCF does but I mean when
somebody's going into into foster care
or whatnot you send somebody out see is
the house clean is it appropriate and
they even go and they do like mini
checks kind of on the grandparents where
the where the children may go so I think
again not not to a huge extended level
like that but just in a go in and see is
a home clean does this person seem
reasonable responsible uh without issue
to kind of give the judge that feedback
I think that would help
to very much so with the problem because
I think we don't have the centers and
I'm not sure that the state would be
able to come up with the centers I think
it's more of a what else can we do since
we don't we don't really have that as an
option anymore I'd like to flag that as
an item that may be uh addressed in the
final report tucked under the ongoing
gal parenting uh continuation of that
subg I want to flag it I I just feel
that needs to be mentioned somewhere in
the interim report even though it's
tucked up under one of the subcommittees
anything else yes represent agree with
you for yes you're welcome go ahead
thank you um and also it's um it's not
it's uh addictions and also child abuse
not I mean DV is part of it but it's the
child abuse or child neglect so um I
think that the our subcommittee would be
good I did miss the um October 17th
meeting but I I think that's a good
place for us to look at that thank you
thank you anybody else no going no other
subcommittees nobody wants a
subcommittee over the December school
vacation got
it bounding no sir we do not um okay I
think we've got enough for the four subc
commmittee chairs to make a report and
please get it to everybody by the end of
the weekend so we can digest it on
Monday and Tuesday I know at least one
person will not be able to be here and
thank you for letting me know but
everybody else if we can come here at
9:30 and go over as a final review of
everything uh for the purpose of any
tweaking and then a final vote and uh
off it goes to um at least the speaker's
office and all of us and anybody else uh
maybe we should charge for it I don't
know that could raise some money for our
party uh how does that sound for next
Tuesday I don't what's that I object to
the party you object to the party I
can't make it uh Tuesday morning I
apologize I'll get everything in advance
though Okie do all we need is everybody
else to be here um excuse me um I'm also
having a conflict on Tuesday is there
any possibility it could be move to um
another day on a Thursday the one I was
just going to ask left the room well we
can Mr chair um if you begin to see that
there might be trouble with the quarum
um uh you can
always uh you can always cancel a
meeting even though it will be
in the calendar the calendar and it
might still be able to be knocked from
the calar for today I don't know but um
in any event you can always cancel and
reschedule okay let me ask the question
who can who will be here on Tuesday I
can't be morning briefly McMahon
Pearson
um the uh spouse of the sidewalk super
she's she's here on her own I know that
representative CG representative long
representative
ball
yeah I can't be here on Tuesday but I
can but I would prefer Thursday um if
it's possible okay I only have you
cannot uh you you will not um I'm
unclear on my times I but I know I
cannot be here I've got I could be here
early and then late I mean okay 9:30 is
it's called for how about let's take a
look at uh let me first want to make
sure I can be
here uh simply for quorum purposes
16th
um yes yeah but okay thank you um yeah I
know she does the scheduling that wasn't
what I wanted her for but I'll take care
of that um thanks Betty yeah thanks
Betty who can be here on the 16th
Thursday at
9:30 who can be here no no no
no yes yes yes yes that's not a
quorum
uh M Mr chair you know it's not as
desirable but this is but you could do
this
without um
a meeting in that you are submitting an
interim report on behalf of the
committee
you could ask and have asked each of us
responsible for a section of this report
to have it to
everybody by uh the start of the
weekend people could get back to
you by Tuesday Tuesday or whatever day
you set and um and they will have either
agreed to all the subsections or will
have made some suggested changes that
would still give you the whatever time
you need to just assemble the pieces
together and
um
uh this is we're not we're not hearing
test ony we're not voting on a bill
we're not doing anything you're calling
the
clerk yeah hi uh representative Pearson
in the middle of a meeting meing a
review on something from the court
please now we're we're trying to we're
trying to make a a policy decision about
whether whether an interim report can be
approved by email if we actually have to
convene to vote because we're having
trouble getting a quorum on dates we're
looking at I don't think the the uh the
the statement coming out of the
speaker's office constituting this
special committee mandated a report but
we're going to have an interim report
and the question is do we all have to be
present in the same room to vote that
report or once it's
ready um ask people by email for their
approval that's the
question okay um let me have him get
back to
you okay um roughly I don't mean to push
but we're about done our business and
going our separate ways how long might
it be before he could answer that
uh I okay thank
you calendar's already
out does anybody have a statement that
constituted The
Establishment speak office I don't have
my folder with
me
I I um have courtesy of Representative
long the initial uh memorandum that
establishes this committee it does not
say anything that I can see about a
final report where it goes or anything
like that the speaker has said to me he
would like to have an interim report
describing our our work uh before we
adjourn until the new year my question
is do we have to approve that report in
person with a quorum or may that interim
report simply be approved by the members
voting via
email
the committee is the special committee
on the Family vision of the Circuit
Court of the State of New
Hampshire that barely fits on one
business
card okay you're trying him on his cell
are
you
okay clerk's office directly cancel
Tuesday
meeting are you still on the phone yes
uh we would like to
cancel our Tuesday meeting we had sent
in a request to have put into the next
calendar a meeting of the special
committee for Tuesday November 14th at
9:30
and the committee would like to cancel
that I as the chair would like to cancel
that meeting so unless the calendar is
already finished the calar was sent out
yesterday Yer it came out yesterday yeah
yeah the veterans we did it day
early that would also need to be done
through the committe services okay that
will have to go through house committee
Services I can do
that I'm
sorry yeah fine that's that's it's fine
like somebody just this morning already
added an addendum there's already a but
that was that's
a an appendix for a hearing to
beum it would go in the addendum anyway
no it
would
the question is how can we
vote because all the dates we're trying
to do Tuesday will not have a quorum so
we can meet on Tuesday November 14th but
since the purpose was to vote we will
lack a quorum we could not get a quorum
for Thursday November 16th either so the
question is since a report is not
mandated in the memorandum that sets us
up is it necessary to meet in person to
approve our interim report or may we do
it by
email and I'd like to speak to the clerk
directly if I
can I know I've been
there
hi Mark hi Paul the um memorandum that
sets up the special committee on Family
Court does not mandate a report but we
would like to give an interim report to
the speaker however we can't find a date
to meet to do it so once the report is
finalized I would like to uh PLL the
committee by email to have them sign off
on it since it's not a mandated thing um
I would hope that we would not have to
try to find you can't if you're going to
adopt something on behalf of the
committee the committee has to vote to
do I agree um so I but I mean it doesn't
have to be before next Friday so I mean
you can do it anytime if you want to do
it in December you can it's just a
matter of finding a time that's GNA be
conducive for you can we do it by email
no we must meet if you're voting if
you're voting to adopt something if
you're adopting something on behalf of
the Comm have to vote to do it yes we we
understand that the question is do we
have to vote in person to do it
yes 91a 991a our dear friend okay thank
you so much all right
by okay okay everybody get calendars out
and let's find a day when we can be
here what about the
2st
oh the 21st is has
chairs and vice chairs meeting in the
morning so you already be here so maybe
we could do it after could
we I have 30 for Thanksgiving which is
very early this week all right everybody
um can't we do it after we can do it
after um trip toan will have worn off by
Sunday okay can we do it on Tuesday
November 28th at 9:30
a.m.
Tuesday November 28th at 9:30 is that
doable I can I can try to ask if I okay
remember I had asked originally save
Tuesdays if possible uh can you do it
I'm I'm unclear but I could get I don't
have all the my dates on the okay
representative Greg yes
long
see give our regards I heard a learned
lecture on leadership trades learn from
the musical and you have to sing it not
speak it yes okay bring back a report
for US Representative can't we move into
December we can move into
December uh I will be on my um oh I have
a better idea Fellowship uh the first
week what okay you go on well I'm
done go ahead what's your idea do it in
December
12th are you back from Manhattan by then
representative long to run the city of
Manchester I hope to be okay can you do
it on the 12th I'm in you're what you're
in man do we all get a turn to go to
Manhattan I never like
JY I think jyn's in Manhattan
Manhattan the drink um yeah no I don't
know I don't know it's in a
Manhattan ver or
whatever
okay what what what
what no what's
that six and and as you know one does
not ever come but I still need six this
is this way the 16th is the thday yeah
how about Thursday the
16th you can come November November 16
you can come you can come you can
come what's
that okay November
16th okay at
9:30 special
committee do not please be dilatory over
the weekend writing your reports however
that still okay so Mr chair what yes
thank you
welcome I cannot be here that day okay
okay I've got I need a I need a quorum
is what I need I have one so there write
that
down okay it's in it's in thank you for
anything else before we adjourn from the
committee okay seeing nothing we're
returned thank
you